I am so tired of talking about work  culture no no free speech is not some  right-wing reframing of whatever it's  the foundation of Western Civilization  upon this civilization is built I don't  have to make the point that has been  made by far better people that the only  way to deal with the problem of racism  is to treat people on the content of  their character  and nothing else and the fact that woke  culture seeks to overturn that is a new  form of racism that we must all oppose I  am not going to talk to those of you who  already agree with me which I imagine is  most of you I want to talk to those of  you who are woke  and who are open to rational argument  a small minority I accept  because one of the tenets of weaknesses  of course that your feelings matter more  than the truth but I believe in you I  believe there are those of you here who  are work who are open to rational  arguments so let me make one